video the first video of the appetizing
serious for the World Championship match
between honored and Carson and it's time
to present the game where one of our
participants is playing with the black
pieces so we've got Anand playing black
iam against Topalov resident Apollo this
game was played in Sofia in the engine
masts tournament of 2006 so also a
couple of years ago let me um put this
game into a context 2006 this means that
at the moment at the start to pile of
was some feat of world champion he had
won this tournament in San Luis and very
convincing fashion we're uh not finished
second and later in 2006
tupelov would play the reunification
match with the kramnik that he lost so
that those is the split which was
started by Kasparov was ended in 2006 so
at the moment this was really a duel of
okay two part of Anand even today would
be a duel on the how does the highest
level but this meant like the absolute
cream of the crop at the moment at this
time so let see what happens the pile of
playing money form and uh non-playing he
5 yeah Hans main openings against a form
f5 the classical way to to play plays
various rule opus lines mostly um he's
going for the marshal but really gets
the chance to play it
he's also playing the night off and
sometimes the cocon but II 5 and C 5 are
his main weapons ok we get a ruler pest
and all this has been played numerous
times and in fact it's quite likely that
we get some ruler pass at the world
championship match as well
Katsidis mostly playing eform these days
but you never know he plays everything
and talents also most seen you for
player with cousin being quite focused
on playing one in five but you never
know in such a match it's not unheard of
that that immediately or suddenly some
some some player is playing an opening
that he has never played before like
let's say Peter let go and his world
championship against kramnik who
suddenly sod to play one d4 which he
never did before the match alright so
back to this game we've gotten to the
starting position of the Marshall so C 3
D 5 would be the Marshall attack and
while being quite aggressive on at first
glance this opening has a reputation of
a draw a shrine on the top level white
is struggling to find anything in this
in this pawn revving lines where blood
gets this active play something like
this this has been analyzed I don't know
probably up to many various end games so
what - Paulo played h3 nowadays is
probably the maintenance avoiding the
pure Marshall and then analyst playing
Bishop d7 the point of h3 is if now g5
and all this quite similar then white
has this additional option which speeds
up his development one problem of the
pure Marshall is that the seats free
porn clock sub wife's development sober
should be 7s the normal response t3 and
rupee eight here d5 in fact an idea
it's not quite quite funny but back then
this idea wasn't wasn't really a
prominent already
okay rupee eight just normal rule a
smooth age six also very useful it's a
preparation amongst others for Bishop of
892 and Bishop evade note that black is
playing this in an interesting fashion
is not yet playing d6 maybe there's
still the chance to play d5 in one move
III yeah also annoying retreat on NATO
and this happens so black plays d6 after
all and 98 this is a very common
maneuver in the rule opus mostly known
from the Brier variation of them
absolute main line night b8 yeah what is
this move doing it frees up the C pawn
to get involved in the game and also
allows if appropriate a regrouping by a
d7 sometimes d7 to c5 or d7 to Boop's no
to b6 is an idea so this is a flexible
move but mostly it's about this this
pawn that it should be involved in the
game 93 and ninety six ninety three is
putting some pressure on c5 and now a
knight c6 and now we see it's a rather
typical situation for further away it's
it's a very very complicated opening
from strategical point of view also
because there are so many parts in the
center and various captures and
transformations are possible just for
example if you think about white playing
D form just for example it's not a
particularly great move probably but
there are so many ways that the strong
the poornam structure could
could transform plan could take here
play this he could immediately advance
he could just stay in the center there
are so many different options so it's
it's almost guaranteed for a complicated
game this opening okay Brooke b1 try to
use Luke on the B file and now we should
see it this is a good move intending to
relocate the bishop maybe even exchange
it on a - it wasn't doing so much on b7
so this is a good regrouping
there should be three and the Bishop to
e6 this also makes sure where the pin
that white cannot take on c5 plate Queen
c2 and rook c8 yeah I think we can take
stop here I think black has a reasonable
position
it's probably about equal Queen B - and
now C for transforming the pawn
structure has mentioned there are many
options to to change it takes and Bishop
takes so on what are the main
strategical ideas what would like to
prevent black from playing d5 because
this would free up their fate bishop and
at the end term like would happen an
extra center pawn the e5 pawn so this is
what black has tried to do and white is
mostly trying to prevent that and we see
that it's very difficult actually to do
so he plays Knight B to d2 and after the
capture and d5 black gets to play as his
idea however it's not the end of the
world white is still in in decent shape
you play rook t1
and Alan played to the Missha smooth
before advancing the deep ol white black
recaptured I'm going through this rather
quickly simply because the main point of
the game is it's just as later the
complications that arise soon um are the
main the main cause of this so when you
know what should why do now we see that
in the deform here there's a rather
tense situation where the rook has
opposed to the Queen so what should why
do it seems that the best move in this
position is Bishop to a form getting out
of this attack and probably it's um it's
about equal here but but whiter can can
still try for something it is it is a
complicated game like for example could
play a 5 just to put something on the
board here white even has ideas to fight
for the initiative d5 and d6 so black
must must be a bit careful maybe a
somewhat slower moves like Queen d7 is
the better choice just centralizing
pieces and continuing to improve your
position white um has one problem if he
plays might be three there's always he
for hang so maybe it's a good idea to to
use the Queen to protect it and then
oops
and then try for night b3 to increase
the pressure this is a complex position
not much and not much going on is wrong
I mean this the the Librium not really
has been disturbed Knight b3 I have a
play / - pol off and
now it gets very tricky took the four
point you can take a central point you
should always seriously consider to do
that and now exactly now we got the
critical position of this game what
should do I do here many you can try to
to analyze a bit for yourself if you
would like to stop the video it's not
them it's not an exercise or a puzzle in
the in the purest sense but try to
figure out what happens on the various
captures on deform and if they are
playable in fact the palace moves now
move now as an escape he can still keep
the game on let's say about about level
with Queen be tuned
however this was very difficult to spot
he played the normal-looking move Bishop
takes d4 but this now leads to an
amazing tactical sequence maybe you can
try to try to calculate a bit like now
token and then note that there is this
idea so if white captures with the night
there's simply night here and it's it's
a fork so rook takes d4 and here black
has a very strong try to try to find it
I'll beside for a couple of seconds so
we make try to find it yourself
and the move is 95 it's not it's not so
difficult to write here because yeah
what what else is there otherwise you
would probably lose just the fall night
but Anand had calculated this far
yeah earlier and yeah what's the point
the queen is saying if white takes the
Queen Justice much I deserve this going
check and like s rook DB one coming and
this is already a win no way that white
is going to survive this hailstorm of
checks both rooks being active and this
is just a very weakened position so it
cannot take the Queen so what is white
supposed to do see if you take on g5
just simply blunt at the house so he
played 95 and it first glance it doesn't
really doesn't really look too
problematic but there's and there's an
amazing point here
I'm not now played they're very strong
and you could toss again if you like
yeah very strong Knight takes h3 check
and yeah what's the point if if white
takes there's some Queen g5 recycled in
the game yeah white could theoretically
speaking a means the king but yeah who
is going to do that black and just just
play Queen g5 right f3 Queen and six and
keep the extra pawn with a good position
to boot so it took it cat Queen g5 check
and King edge - and at this at this
moment you you could think
hmm surely rook takes e5 right but what
happens after form look something no can
till queen g6 and then rookie v problem
is there's this threat and also the
saying so this is the only booth can in
this line however look at the check in
this position black is probably winning
in the long run but it's still work to
do in the game however i want to take on
e5 because there is a much stronger move
and to see that beforehand is is really
excellent
he played Queen f5 and this is very very
strong
what's the point yeah that's that's a
double threat now there's Luke takes me
five without any harassment of f4 and
that's the even be a threat Roxy to
breaking through on on f2 at the same
time the Queen is eyeing this de-spawn
so it's it's a big threat and ya still
if I think what should buy do what could
you could try that move covering a five
but then there's the very direct group
takes five five check and this one at
the end and white is completely
completely busted
threatening made and there's no defense
this duo here is it's not this king is
nicely defended by the by the bishop so
like it's just enjoying a mating attack
with rook down but I think why does all
pieces near the King but they are not
coordinated at all
this is Queenie ^ plate rookie form and
yeah what now again this is protected
and there's no roof situ has another
overlooked something nope there's
another sacrifice rook Chengzhi v rook
takes e5 and Bishop d6 setting up in the
bishop which I only had a defensive role
just a moment ago now enters the game
and with decisive effect this is just a
deadly pin how should should white
cavalry five if you go here then there's
again this check this business and
there's no perpetual check you can give
a couple of checks but at the end
there's a five and this is this is too
much so it's it's a pin and white is not
coordinated at all he played night 9 to
c5 John just took it King G - and now
the finishing touch rooks his six the
good old look lifts activating the rook
in the attack and all blacks pieces
attack while this Knight is a bit of
side
and yeah what plate Queen b3 check King
f1 and Bishop g3 and here the pile of
resigned the game there's absolutely
nothing white could do this is hanging
with check there's a mate threat and
white has absolutely no counter play so
a really drastic loss for the world
champion at that time to Paul of being
the feat of world champion I think what
I always liked about this game is that
it's it's such an out-of-the-blue tactic
I mean in this position you you somehow
feel that hmm isn't black and that's a
bit tricky for black being here opposed
the rook and somehow quite out of the
blue there is this tactical head storm
coming down on white which you really
don't expect to happen it's all based on
one factor the knight on B 3 and the
Queen on a to those tactical skirmishes
that are very much favorable for one
side very often a cost by the Queen
especially the Queen being offside I
mean just imagining it's it's pure
theoretical thing but the Queen would be
on d2 or somewhere else just on d2 on b2
and it would help in the defense but or
cover the first rank the queen is on a2
and a2 where is is unprotected and it's
not really taking part in the game so in
fact after Knight g5 it's it's already
losing for what there's no way to just
to save the game everything's hanging by
a thread gem and it's one of the most
out of the blue tactical shots that that
I know so it shows them a remarkable
strength of Ana's he's a very good
technical player if it's complicated and
dynamic he's very rarely missing things
so I'm really nice quick quick win with
like against a very strong opponent I
hope you enjoyed the game maybe you
could do a bit of calculating yourself
all right
until tomorrow thanks for watching